THAN ABOUT BEING MORALLY RIGHT.
>> Sean: HERE IS SOUTH CAROLINA
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
SENATOR, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
BY THE WAY,  THE WORLD IS ENDING
IN 12 YEARS.
>> THAT'S WHAT I HEAR.
>> Sean: A LOT OF ISSUES HERE.
HOW COULD ANYBODY LOOK IN THE
EYE OF A PARENT THAT LOST A KID
FROM A HEROIN OVERDOSE AND NOT
SAY -- OR SAY THAT THIS IS
MANUFACTURED OR LOOK IN THE FACE
OF AN ANGEL MOM OR DAD, SAME
ISSUE THERE, AND NOT EVEN BE
WILLING TO TALK ABOUT THE ISSUE
WITH THE PRESIDENT BUT IT'S LIFE
AND DEATH, SAFETY AND SECURITY,
AND THEN PUT OUT ALL OF THESE
DEMANDS.
IT MAKES IT IMPOSSIBLE.
>> WHAT YOU DON'T HAVE IS CLIPS
OF DEMOCRATIC SENATORS SAYING
THIS BECAUSE THEY KNOW IT'S A
DEATH BLOW TO THE PARTY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE A BRILLIANT
POLITICAL MOVE AND GOOD FOR THE
COUNTRY TO GO TO THE MIDDLE.
WALL PLUS DACA PLUS TPS.
I'VE HAD MORE DEMOCRATIC
SENATORS TALK TO ME IN THE LAST
TWO DAYS THAN TALK TO ME IN THE
LAST 30 DAYS.
THE HARDER NANCY PELOSI GOES
LEFT AND THE MORE TRUMP GOES TO
THE MIDDLE, WE'RE GOING TO GET
THIS THING SOLVED.
>> Sean: TOMORROW, I CAN SEE
CHUCK SCHUMER WINDING UP ALL THE
DEMOCRATS TO VOTE ON THAT
COMPROMISE PLAN.
TPA, DACA, DREAMERS, AND BY THE
WAY THE HOUSE WANTING TO PAY THE
FURLOUGHED EMPLOYEES.
NO DEMOCRATS SUPPORTING THAT
EITHER.
I GUESS THAT WAS A LIE ALSO.
>> YOU'LL HAVE A VOTE TOMORROW
ON THE PRESIDENT'S PLAN THAT
WILL GET ALMOST ALL REPUBLICANS,
VERY FEW DEMOCRATS.
WE'LL HAVE SCHUMER'S PROPOSAL,
THAT I'LL VOTE AGAINST.
THEN THE HARD WORK STARTS.
WE HAD A MEETING TODAY WITH
EIGHT DEMOCRATS AND EIGHT
REPUBLICANS.
NANCY PELOSI HAS BECOME A
NIGHTMARE FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
SHE SEEMS UNREASONABLE.
SHE SEEMS TO HAVE A DISLIKE FOR
THE PRESIDENT THAT IS HURTING
THE COUNTRY.
THIS IDEA OF NOT LETTING THE
PRESIDENT SPEAK IS REALLY
OVERPLAYING YOUR HAND.
I WANT YOUR LISTENERS TO KNOW
THAT THERE'S A REACTION TO THIS
FAR LEFT RHETORIC IN THE SENATE
BY MORE MAINSTREAM DEMOCRATS
THAT I THINK WILL EVENTUALLY
ALLOW US TO GET THE WALL FUNDED
AND DO SOME THINGS FOR THE DACA
RECIPIENTS AND TPS RECIPIENTS.
THEREst A DEAL IN THE -- THERE'S
A DEAL IN THE MAKING.
AND THE MORE EXTREME NANCY
PELOSI GETS, THE MORE LIKELY
WE'LL HAVE A DEAL.
>> IT CAN'T INCLUDE AMNESTY,
YOU'RE GOING TO LOSE --
>> IT WON'T.
IT WILL NOT.
I PROMISE YOU IT WILL NOT.
>> Sean: OKAY.
ET SEEMS LIKES NANCY PELOSI
IS -- IT SEEMS LIKE NANCY PELOSI
IS INTIMIDATED AND AFRAID OF
THIS NEW RADICAL EXTREME
ELEMENT.
>> I THINK SO.
>> Sean: WHAT IS YOUR TAKE AND
INTERPRETATION OF THE
CONSTITUTION ARTICLE II SECTION
3.
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT HAS A
LOT OF POWER.
SHE CAN DECEMBER INVITE HIM TO
THE HOUSE, BUT COME TO THE
SENATE, MR. PRESIDENT.
THERE'S PLENTY OF PLACES THE
PRESIDENT CAN CHOOSE TO DELIVER
THE STATE OF THE UNION.
HERE'S THE QUESTION FOR AMERICA.
WHAT KIND OF UNION DO YOU WANT?
DO YOU WANT A COUNTRY THAT LOOKS
MORE LIKE VENZ
MORE LIKE VEEZUELA AND LESS
LIKE AMERICA?
THEY'RE GOING TO TAKE YOU TO THE
LAND WHERE THE GOVERNMENT TAXES
EVERYTHING IN ITS POWER.
THEY CONTROL EVERY DECISION IN
LIFE.
AND YOU'LL SEE VENEZUELA COME
HERE.
THIS IS WHAT THIS WHOLE ELECTION
IS GOING TO BE ABOUT IN 2020.
DO WE GO FURTHER LEFT AND
WELCOME LIKE VENEZUELA OR DO WE
BECOME THE AMERICA THAT ALL OF
US WANT US TO BE.
IF I'M A DEMOCRAT, THESE PEOPLE
ARE DEFINING MY PARTY IN A WAY
THAT GIVES IT A VERY LIMITED
FUTURE IN AMERICA, IN MY VIEW.
>> Sean: SO THE PRESIDENT TO ME
OBVIOUSLY -- AND I AGREE WITH
HIM -- VIEWS THIS AS LIFE AND
DEATH, SAFETY AND SECURITY OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
STOPPING THE HEROIN -- 90% OF
THE HEROIN IN THIS COUNTRY FROM
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER,
FENTANYL.
THAT SEEMS LIKE A PRINCIPLED,
STRONG POSITION, ALSO PART OF
HIS -- WHEN HE PLEDGES TO
FAITHFULLY SERVE AND PROTECT THE
CONSTITUTION, THAT MEANS ITS
PEOPLE, HE'S THE COMMANDER IN
CHIEF AS PER THE CONSTITUTION.
WHAT IS THE DEMOCRATIC POSITION?
THEY DON'T WANT DACA.
THEY DON'T SEEM TO CARE ABOUT
FURLOUGHED EMPLOYEES.
DREAMERS.
WHAT IS THIS FIGHT ABOUT THEN
FOR THEM?
>> THEY WANT TRUMP TO FAIL MORE
THAN THEY WANT THE COUNTRY TO
WIN.
A DOLLAR FOR THE WALL.
DOES THAT MAKE SENSE IN LIGHT OF
THE CARAVANS THAT HAVE BEEN
COMING?
A BROKEN BORDER IS MORE
DANGEROUS TO THE COUNTRY THAN A
PARTIAL GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
IN THEIR WORLD, THERE IS NO
I.C.E.
YOU GET A DOLLAR FOR THE WALL
AND THE BORDER PATROL AGENTS ARE
GASSING CHILDREN, NOT DEFENDING
THE COUNTRY FOR AN ONSLAUGHT.
MY VIEW IS THAT DEMOCRATS IN THE
SENATE ARE GOING TO BECOME MORE
REASONABLE AS THESE PEOPLE
DEFINE EXTREME POSITIONS.
THE PRESIDENT MADE A VERY SMART
MOVE BY PUTTING ON THE TABLE
RELIEF FOR DACA RECIPIENTS, TPS
YIP SENTS, WHICH THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE BEEN FOR FOR DECADES.
NOW LET'S SEE WHAT KIND OF
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WE'VE GOT.
DO WE HAVE A DEMOCRATIC PARTY
THAT HATES TRUMP SO MUCH THEY
WILL SAY NO TO 1.1 MILLION
PEOPLE HAVING A BETTER LIFE?
OR WILL WE HAVE SOME DEMOCRATIC
SENATORS AND HOUSE MEMBERS JOIN
WITH THE PRESIDENT AND ME TO
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM?
TIME WILL TELL.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT, IT
SEEMS, HE DOES HAVE OTHER
OPTIONS.
>> YES, HE DOES.
>> Sean: GANGS, CARTELS, HUMAN
TRAFFICKING, DRUG TRAFFICKING,
REAL RADICAL ELEMENTS.
I BELIEVE THE OTHER 98% THAT
DON'T RESPECT OUR LAWS, BUT THEY
COME HERE FOR A BETTER LIFE FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILIES.
I BELIEVE THAT HAVING BEEN DOWN
THERE A LOT.
THEN THE QUESTION IS WHEN THE
PRESIDENT GOES ALONE, NATIONAL
EMERGENCY, WHAT HAPPENS NEXT?
>> IF I WERE HIM, I WOULD USE MY
POWER AS COMMANDER IN CHIEF TO
BUILD THAT WALL BECAUSE HE
PROMISED TO BUILD IT.
EVERY DEMOCRAT HAS VOTED FOR
WALL FUNDING EXCEPT WHEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP BECAME
PRESIDENT.
IF I WERE THE PRESIDENT, I WOULD
ASK NANCY PELOSI IF A BILL
PASSES THE SENATE THAT HAS WALL
FUNDING, PROTECTION FOR DACA AND
TPS, WOULD YOU TAKE IT UP IN THE
HOUSE.
IF SHE SAYS YES, I WOULD OPEN
THE GOVERNMENT FOR THREE WEEKS,
LET THE SENATE SEE IF WE CAN
REACH A DEAL.
IF WE CAN'T, I WOULD USE THE
EMERGENCY POWERS AS THE
COMMANDER IN CHIEF TO BRING THIS
DEBACLE TO AN END.
>> I'M NOT SURE IF HE GIVES UP
HIS LEVERAGE.